well it's January a lot of people
talking about their new diets if you
found that to be true yeah okay
thank you one person go so many people
are talk about their diets I thought I'd
just take a second and talk about mine
yeah you are you are very enthusiastic
about your diet yeah how about it yeah
yeah the diets not complicated really
it's just here's what you do eat a lot
of lean proteins and vegetables you cut
out all grains you cut out starches corn
probably on the list and cut out and
should also make sure that you cut up as
a whoo
I had to get out of there there's
nothing more boring than when someone
starts talking about their diet that is
only interesting to you pal
I mean I'm working here I can barely
pretend to care okay I better get back
up maybe and a half of steamed broccoli
no oil that's important no oil and I'm
good to go
[ __ ] that that's pretty fascinating you
know speaking of broccoli the other
night at dinner my wife said the
funniest thing she pointed out how
broccoli looked like little trees and so
then I said well that's probably you
gotta be kidding me
I mean there's nothing worse than when
someone tries to explain a joke you
weren't there for I wasn't there it's
never gonna make sense and I just have
to pretend to laugh I gotta get back and
so then she says don't tell DeNiro
[Laughter]
see obviously you had to be there wait
you hate my stories no Annie no I didn't
I didn't I don't hate your stories no
I'm just yanking your chain I hate his
stories too he's a bore
oh my god thank God I thought it was
just me that hated that guy stories oh
please whenever he starts talking that's
my cue to nap hey great idea you know I
like this Andy a lot better than that
other Andy oh and I like this Conan so
much better than the other Conan oh man
I gotta tell you Andy I hate this Conan
he's a dick hey you want to go get a
drink yeah sure he doesn't drink much
but I'm an alcoholic
yeah let's go get messed up yeah all
right well ladies and gentlemen we got
I'll be right there we got a great show
tonight from the CBS all access series
Star Trek Discovery actor-comedian very
good friend of ours TIG Notaro
good luck with this guy we'll see in a
second